Amazon seems to really really enjoy
torturing us they seem to enjoy taking
our favorite shows and making us wait
for them we've waited for Stargate and
we've been waiting for the
expanse Alcon want to take the expanse
elsewhere but Amazon might have second
thoughts this is a bit of a shocker
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
Movie Channel there's been a little bit
of a drama ever since season six of the
expanse ended people were very excited
about the possibility of more of the
series naron Shankar the showrunner
actually said that this show wasn't dead
it was just an an Hiatus they were just
taking a bit of a
break but nearly two years on we've
still heard nothing solid about the
return of the series we've heard many
rumors s we know that Alcon the
production company that owned the
expanse are very interested in it
continuing with the series in some way
we've heard rumors actually very early
on that Amazon were even considering
making a series of movies to complete
the books those rumors ended quite
quickly when it became clear that even
though they looked at the possibility
they decided for several reasons it
wasn't feasible one they just thought
that actually the books were way too big
and two expansive to make into TV movies
basically and that they couldn't do it
justice also that it would cost way too
much money considering the return they
considered the show was actually
worth but Alcon never gave up and they
did start asking other companies whether
they might be interested now initially I
told you that Warner Brothers was the
front runner and they were particularly
interested in doing a spin-off series
and potentially TV movie and then maybe
eventually going into book Seven but
those interests really sort of waned
after David zaz took over and changed
the direction of Warner Brothers into
more producing material for others
rather than producing things for HBO Etc
but Apple TV seemed to continue that
interest and I'm being told that
interest is still very real like Warner
Brothers they don't necessarily want to
jump straight into doing season 7 if you
don't know the books do have a gap
between book six and book Seven of about
30 years so it did make sense for Amazon
to end the series where they did because
of this Gap but also Apple believe it
gives them the opportunity to do
spin-off series something that's
completely new not based on any of the
books perhaps based on some of the beta
Cannon or something else that Ty Frank
and Daniel Abraham would produce for
them that it would be a really nice way
to separate the TV show from what Amazon
had already done the original six
seasons so that it could be the expanse
but apples the expanse if you are
enjoying the video don't forget to like
subscribe do all those things but also
throw a thumbs up and throw on a comment
it really does help us with all those
pesky little YouTube
algorithms Apple's thinking though was
also that that could lead into movies as
well Apple seemed to be looking at this
as a really interesting addition to
their already impressive sci-fi catalog
but there has been a massive twist in
the tail because one of my sources
contacted me last night and I have
spread the word out with a couple of
other sources and I'm getting a similar
story now I do have to say immediately
this is very much in the rumor category
there are certain things I know for
certain but unfortunately to protect the
source I can't actually tell you a lot
of that because it would identify the
source quite easily so we do have to
read between the lines a little bit and
we do have to surmise what certain
things mean so for one I can tell you
that there are certain agents and
certain people that are connected to the
expanse that are in contact with Alcon
because they are actually still
contracted with Alon to produce anything
the expanse related in the future if
Alcon were to do it so if Alcon go to
Apple those companies and those
individuals would potentially still be
contracted to be involved that does
include penguin and the Parker the
company that um actually developed the
show which is Haw host to be and Mark
fergus's company names that you know
very well if you're a regular Sid
tracker because those are the guys we're
hoping are going to be taking on
Stargate there's also several actors
that are potentially liable to return
now those actors and those companies are
seeking a little bit of clarification
and they've gone through a third party
to get that clarification on the
contract situation because Alcon have
approached Amazon to bring the end date
of their current contract with Amazon
forwards they want to end the contract
now now what contract am I talking about
well
Amazon has a first dibs contract with
Alcon for the expanse they have a
distribution and a production contract
with them they basically bought the
expanse for Amazon from Alcon they said
to Alcon we're going to give you a load
of money and you're going to produce
some lovely lovely expanse seasons for
our Channel but Amazon have stopped
making the expanse so why is this
contract still valid well the contract
basically said that the rights would
revert back to Alcon but only only after
a certain time period basically Amazon
has to not produce a new TV show or
movie or anything for a set period of
time that set period of time was we
believed around two years but it
actually looks like it's roughly two
years and six months because the source
telling me that actually that contract
or that time scale Runs Out in late
summer
2024 alhan had approached Amazon to
bring that time scale forwards they
basically went to Jeff and went dude
come on you're not doing anything with
it can we just have it back please it's
one of our biggest most valuable
properties and it's just Gathering dust
we're not making any money go on go on
be a pal and Amazon's reply allegedly
was we still might do something with it
now this was a shock to Alcon because
now apparently Amazon are considering
doing a spin-off series of their own
they've took Warner brother's idea
they've took Apple Plus's idea and
they've gone that's all right let's do
that I don't know what stage sort of
Amazon's thinking is I don't know if
this is just a oh who whoa wait up hold
your horses we haven't said we're not
doing anything with it yet or if this is
actually Amazon just basically taking a
pause because they don't want the show
to go across to Apple or Warner Brothers
maybe this is even Jeff Bezos stepping
in and going I freaking love the expanse
why aren't you doing something with it
before the time lapse will you please
have a look and maybe throw me some
options now Jeff Bezos isn't in charge
of Amazon anymore but he still is
obviously a massively influential figure
and he is a fan of the expanse so if he
did get involed involved it could
trigger the Amazon Executives to just go
to Alcon giz a sec we're not sure what
we want to do just yet now this has
thrown Alcon into a bit of a bloody tail
spin for one thing about six months ago
they sold all the sets and all the props
and everything for the show they sold it
all partly because they needed the money
but partly because what they were
basically planning to do would be a
complete spin-off show Apple were
talking about doing something much
smaller in scale than the original
expans Seasons that it would be a far
more character-driven show but with a
much smaller cast so it would be a far
more focused TV show they were also
doing something that would be separate
from Amazon so Apple were talking about
wanting to do something that was very
different and looked different even
though it would still feel like the
expanse it would be set aboard different
Starships blah blah blah so they had all
of these props Etc that they didn't need
and thanks to the strikes and the
pandemic they basically had an asset
worth selling that they needed to sell
but now all of a sudden Amazon might be
wanting to do something else and am and
Alcon don't have the sets and the props
anymore there is also though an ongoing
rumor that I've heard now several times
and had had repeated to me about a week
ago that naron Shankar Daniel Abraham
and Ty Frank is still in talks to create
their own production company now this is
a production company that would
basically step in for penguin and a
Parker if they did do more material
because penguin and Parker have moved on
they're doing a couple of other projects
for Amazon and hopefully they're going
to be taken on Stargate so this new
production company by the original
writers and the showrunner of the series
would basically step into that role
creating scripts doing all the
development work etc etc I'm hearing
that that is still a distinct
possibility and the only reason we
haven't heard anything yet is because
because they are waiting for something
definitive from Alcon Amazon Apple to
say yes we want you to go ahead with it
once they do I think that company will
get created quite quickly and that they
will take the lead in producing the new
show for whoever it is that ends up
doing it is Amazon just messing with
Alcon is Amazon just pausing because you
know they don't want the show to go to
someone else get into the comments and
tell me what you think think what the
bloody hell is Amazon actually playing
at because this is a show that we would
love to see return in some form I
actually think some sort of spin-off
show something that fills that 30-year
Gap would be amazing so is Amazon mad
for even waiting this long is this a
show that desperately needs to come back
get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos also you can go to
patreon.com sitre where most of our new
videos Premiere first and you get to see
them without the adverts for a small
contribution that really helps a channel
out also you can go to
c.co which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on a lot of
our videos and we try to add a little
bit more information for you to digest
go check it out as always please stay
safe and I'll see you next
time